ja die neue panikmache mit corona der
kampf um den vierten lockdown dabei
haben ja alle das ja noch so gut im kopf
die warnungen wenn ihr nicht das oder
jenes tut dann habt ihr ja dann hat er
drohte zu verantworten das kennen wir
alle noch zu gut aus der zweiten welle
ich will lieber sagen wenn wir jetzt vor
weihnachten zu viele kontakte und
anschließend ist das letzte weihnachten
mit den großeltern war dann werden wir
etwas versäumt haben das sollten wir
einen stuhl wie viel tote sind uns denn
jetzt ganz konkret ein shoppingerlebnis
wert wie viel tote wollen wir denn in
kauf nehmen für einen schönen
restaurantbesuch die wirkung der
maßnahmen kommt nicht so käme nicht dann
hätten wir also in zwei monaten pro tag
tatsächlich 500.000 neue infizierte
dabei ist doch jetzt sommer dabei sind
die zahlen doch so im keller
dabei fühlt man sich doch jetzt endlich
wieder die freiheit die wir alle so
vermisst haben so nagl schon einmal auf
die aktuellen zahlen denn es geht jetzt
endlich mit dem impfen voran und alles
andere geht ja auch runter immer wurde
ja verkündet das impfen das ist der
einzige weg aus dem loch down und der
pandemie und der blick auf die grafik
verspricht auch genau das 81,9 3
millionen menschen sind geimpft also
58,5 einmal und 42,6 prozent sind in
deutschland bereits vollständig geimpft
70 prozent auch das eine wichtige zahl
aller 60 jährigen sind durchgeimpft also
für diese besonders beachtenswerte
gruppe in dieser pandemie die sind schon
in sicherheit schon einmal auf die lage
in ganz deutschland denn auch die ist
durchaus erfreulich wir sehen hier und
ich erinnere mich noch an die zeiten als
hier teilweise alles nur in rot und gelb
ein gefährt war ein komplett grünes
deutschland die zahlen sie gehen runter
und die institute liegt nicht die
wahlkarte alcadis die korona hotspot
karte die größe vollständig grün ist
mittlerweile ja heute morgen lag die
instanz in deutschland bei 6,5 alle
bundesländer instanz von unter 10 den
goldenen pokal den verleihen wir heute
an sachsen anhalt 1,4 die niedrigste
incidence in deutschland wenn das nicht
mal grund für optimismus jetzt ja aber
im gegenteil ist läuft schon wieder die
vorbereitung einer nächsten locker und
wälle julian wie ist das wie ist das zu
erklären warum ist die stimmung in der
politik aktuell so anders als in der
bevölkerung also ich glaube wir müssen
erstmal für unsere zuschauer noch einmal
ganz kurz auf diese politiker videos
darum einfach eingehen weil das ist
etwas was wir auch in der historischen
rückschau auf corona
vergessen sollte dass uns der regierende
bürgermeister von berlin ja das
regierungsoberhaupt sozusagen von vier
millionen menschen dort tatsächlich
erzählt wie viele tote wollen wir für
ein shopping erlebnis in kauf nehmen hat
einfach mit der welt der fakten nie
etwas zu twittern aller für die linke
nicht kennen sollten den regierenden
bürgermeister von der schlechtesten
bürgermeister die dieses land jemals
gesehen hat auch einer der nervigste in
seinen in seiner internierung in seinen
pressekonferenzen aber vor allem jemand
der offenbar ist für vollkommen
angemessen hält das konzept von
angstmacherei ohne jegliche faktenbasis
als grundlage für politik zu betrachten
es hat in deutschland keine toten durch
shopping erlebnisse gegeben es hat auf
der ganzen welt keinen nachweisbaren
toten oder keine signifikante oder
irgendwie messbare zahl aufgrund von
shopping erlebnis haben aber wir haben
es gesehen genauso wurde politik gemacht
und da muss es uns nicht wundern dass
genauso jetzt wieder politik gemacht
wird nämlich mit der angstmacherei vor
einer nicht ausreichenden impfquote auf
einmal heißt es wenn nicht 85 prozent
sind dann können wir gar nicht mehr so
wirklich raus aus diesem master man hat
das gefühl die politik hat eine solche
lust daran und eine solche freude daran
geworden uns in diesen maßnahmen
konstrukt in diesem teilweise wirklicher
freiheitsrecht beraubenden maßnahmen
konstrukt zu halten dass sie gar nicht
mehr davon lassen will und ich glaube
ein punkt den man sieht der gerade der
ist besonders toxisch es treffen sich
gerade sozusagen das ende einer großen
ära angela merkel 16 jahre die natürlich
daran denkt wie werde ich in den
geschichtsbüchern dastehen und der
wahlkampf aufeinander
wir und wir sehen dass sowohl im
wahlkampf als auch in der ja eher in der
geschichts bewahrung die dort aus dem
merkel-lager beziehung wird wie gut
waren wir in der pandemie ein
grauenvolles argument die oberhand
gewonnen hat wer anderer meinung ist ist
schuld am tod anderer menschen damit
wird inzwischen politik macht gewisser
anderer meinung das ist tödlich für
andere menschen so wird inzwischen
politik gemacht einerseits im kanzleramt
um sozusagen die
zählung zu bewahren wir hatten mit allem
recht wir lagen ich falsch seien
katastrophal falsch mit so vielen dingen
besonders was unsere kinder andere im
kanzleramt aber auch im wahlkampf auf
einmal wird er mit politik gemacht wer
anderer meinung ist bringt den tod das
sind konzepte die wollen wir nicht in
der demokratie
die dürfen keinen einzigen demokratie
haben wir hier bei den sagen ist immer
laut aber man muss auch sagen ganz viele
medien in deutschland machen lustvoll
bei diesem konzept mit und haben sich da
inzwischen wirklich in den dienst dieser
propaganda rhetorik gestellt was glaubst
du denn wie werden wir den herbst gehen
denn viele menschen lesen all das
höheren alters und fürchten sich vor dem
herbst fügen sie von der data variante
fürchten auch ich zum beispiel ganz
konkret die schulschließungen wieder
mein sohn wird jetzt eingeschult und ich
sehe mich jetzt schon im homeschooling
eingeschult wird kann heute sehen ob er
eingeschult wird ich sehe dass
tatsächlich noch nicht wie gehen wir in
den herbst wir wissen eine sache wie wir
in den herbst gibt begehen geimpft in
den herbst im herbst wird jeder deutsche
die möglichkeit gehabt haben für sich zu
entscheiden möchte ich mich impfen
lassen ja oder nein möchte ich das
risiko tragen ungeimpft durch die welt
von corona zu gehen ja oder nein und
damit dass jeder mensch diese
entscheidung frei treffen konnte gibt es
keinerlei grund oder berechtigung oder
rechtfertigung für die politik mehr
irgendjemanden irgendwie vorzuschreiben
ich kann es immer nur wieder sagen
patricia julian sagen jetzt lass uns mal
wieder in die kirche gehen und singen es
ist verboten in diesem land und ich
verstehe bis heute nicht warum angela
merkel uns in einer welt des impfens
verbieten kann in der kirche zu singen
ich verstehe es nicht und man kann es
nicht auf die mutter amüsiert sein nie
wieder lockt das müsste das muss ja gut
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren